and though when dave filoni when they
when the offer came in about
more than 10 years now to do the voice
of bogotan
right in clone wars yeah um i jumped
like i didn't even it wasn't even like i
think twice it was like of course that's
amazing a female mandalorian warrior
um a hello of course and i remember
multiple times as we were sort of doing
this dave and i joking
about you know one day
um if this happens you know she could
exist in these worlds you know and i
just
kept sort of saying tongue-in-cheek
things like that because
i honestly was just taking the piss i
never
like you see amazing things and and i'm
not going to say that amazing things
haven't happened in my career
i've had such a beautiful career i work
my ass off
um but i have had a beautiful career and
there have been great things
but you see i've seen people around me
get that big huge massive thing you know
and you go
wow so proud of them so excited for them
it's amazing because if it happens to
someone else
there's still hope right but it can
happen to you
but it's never happened to me like it
never like that big
huge thing had never happened so
i always joked with him just thinking of
course they'll recast it they'll
probably hire scarlett johansson or
something like that
um but when mandalorian came out and i
saw him
at um at a celebration
i made a joke about you know
bogutan wink wink nudge nudge i said you
know i've
been playing characters like this for 15
years buddy
um and i never i never really thought it
would happen
um i was just sort of joking well let me
ask you this before i want you to finish
this because i love it yeah but what i
think of is
name one actor
who has played the animated version of a
character and then the live action
i i haven't i've never played lex luthor
animated
i've never played flash live action in
fact
lex luthor's been recast in in many ways
i haven't been considered
i'm not angry probably am but was or
but anyway yeah so this is i can't name
one so the fact that you were boca raton
i'm just kidding i know florida
it's a phase two phase two book every
time
um playing bokeh tan
as the voice and then playing getting
the live action it's just
no it's unheard of they never do it no
one has a because no one thinks outside
the box no one thinks
it's not even outside the box no one
thinks inside the box no one just goes
of course look at this actress but
anyway but continue
yeah no i think sometimes they think
that if you hit the nail on the head
um it was too easy and it wasn't
inspired enough
for some reason um so they try to think
outside the box
so much so um that they sometimes get it
wrong i guess
and they sometimes get it right um but
yeah it was this moment where
i was always just joking and when a
phone call came in that
john favreau wanted to sit down with me
i almost had a heart attack
i